I've sat there with some of my close
billionaire friends they got all nine
cars that I've ever dreamed of running
up outside and they tell me at 4:00 a.m.
by their indoor pool that they're deeply
unhappy and ask me to sleep in their bed
with them that night because they're
lonely there is a period in everybody's
Journey where they are so different
because they've started to do new things
that they no longer fit in with their
old set of friends but they're not
sufficiently developed that they've
gained their new set of friends and
they're unsure should I go back should I
lean back into getting a bad game with
the boys on a weekend is that the
highest you know way that I can live my
life passion forward CU that's what
everybody else does and all of my
friends are taking the piss oh not
drinking again too good for us are we
not going out again this week oh okay
well like enjoy staying in home and
reading so you're going to feel the pain
of being ostracized from the group of
friends that you used to have but you're
stuck in this messy Middle where you
haven't yet worked out who you are on
the other side of this and that lonely
chapter I I would say almost nobody that
I've ever met who has gone from a place
where they are to a place where they
want to be hasn't gone through